API design is something that as a
backend engineer you will spend a lot of
time working on and thinking about and
it is one of the most important videos
in this playlist and in this video we
are going to talk a lot about uh
designing apis a lot of Concepts
surrounding uh apis in general and we'll
be mostly focusing on rest API there are
different technologies that people use
to build API
uh we have RPC calls and we have graphql
etc etc so in this one we are going to
only focus on rest API one of the most
used API standards now the problem with
API design is we have all these
resources and we also have this common
standard which is called a rest API or
restful API standard and years of
research and many many developers
particularly backend Engineers
experience over the years and but still
even now when someone who is learning
backend or in the early stages of their
journey into backend engineering they
still get confused by certain questions
questions like should the URI path
segment be plural or singular or when
updating a resource should you call
patch or should you call put right
different different http methods and
also if it's a non- crud operation
meaning if it's not a fetch operation or
create operation or an update operation
or a delete operation it's it's a custom
action something that you want the
server to perform it's called an action
call so which method should you use
since it it sounds like update should
you go with patch orput or since it's
creating something should you post etc
etc like questions like these and also
what uh HTTP status code to use for
different different scenarios a lot of
questions like this even now we still
get confused about all these questions
and the reason is when people were
developing these standards uh these
widespread HTTP API standards the state
of the internet and the state of the web
and the state of the clients and the
state of the servers were very different
from what we have today and and
previously when these standards were
being developed we were heavily using
MPS also known as uh multi-page
applications and these days if you uh
are aware of the front end side of the
ecosystem then we heavily make use of
single page applications know where in
the first API call the browser makes a
request and downloads all the JavaScript
that is required required and it
performs all the routing on the client
side using the browser's path and URL
etc etc it's a completely client side a
client heavy application now the purpose
of this video uh is to standardize not
to create new standards but as the
standards already exist to extract
certain rules and guidelines from this
existing standards we aim to stick to
these guidelines to make it as
convenient as possible possible for
everyone to follow A single standard and
a consistent styling pattern when
designing apis know designing apis
designing payloads and documentation etc
etc everything surrounding API design
this way we won't have to question these
issues anymore these common issues that
backend Engineers face in day-to-day
lives we can simply move forward with
our development now we already have this
standard in place and by sticking to
them we can focus on our business logic
instead of worrying about whether our
API is restful or not or whether we are
following the latest industry standards
or not etc etc so in this video we will
explore API design from end to end
starting from how to design your
resources how to design your routes how
to return success responses how to
return error responses which status code
to use what kind of data to accept and
much much more essentially everything
related to API design so that we can
concentrate on our business logic after
this video we can move on from standards
and we'll get into execution phase now
before we start about the technical
stuff the actual API designing part
let's talk a little bit about the
history of where we are coming from and
why we are talking about it so that we
have a little more context so in 1990
Tim berners Le started a project called
the worldwide web to share knowledge
with the whole world that was the
initial motivation for starting what we
call as Internet today and this project
was built to facilitate the sharing of
knowledge and information globally and
with that goal team mesly within a year
or so invented all these different
concepts or Technologies first one URI
what we call as uniform resource
identifier second one HTTP the HTTP
protocol that uh we use
underneath to communicate between client
and servers we have already covered how
HTTP works and etc etc in previous video
so you can check that out third HTML
HTML is basically the markup language
which we use to construct web pages what
you can call is the skeleton of a page
fourth the first web server fifth the
first web browser and sixth the first
what you see is what you get editor an
HTML editor which was built directly
into the browser now he built all these
things which we still use today by the
way and we use the advanced and the more
developed version of all these
Technologies we still use Uris we still
use make use of HTTP protocols now uh it
started with HTTP 1.1 then now we have
HTTP 2.0 and 3.0 etc etc we still make
use of
HTML right we still use HTML we have a
lot of different types of web servers
these days we have a lot of different
types of browsers these days etc etc and
we also have the browsers uh in built
HTML editor right so he invented and he
came up with all these new technologies
and Concepts within an year or so but
soon now the problem arises the problem
was the project which was known as the
worldwide web was headed towards
breakdown because of the exponential
growth of its user base within a short
period of time a lot of users a lot of
people started using this new technology
which is known as the worldwide web and
the Creator uh Team Bal Le he had not
accounted for all this uh scale all this
number of users when he was building the
project this was not accounted for so to
scale the web to accommodate this large
user base new techniques standards and
components had to be introduced the
previous one the all the mindsets and
all the Technologies and all the
planning that went behind creating or
coming up with all these Technologies
was not enough to scale the web to
account for the huge user base that it
was acquiring every day it was scaling
exponentially now at this point we have
one other major contributor to the
project web so around
1993 Roy Fielding the co-founder of the
Apache HTTP server project became
concerned about the web scalability
problem that we just talked about the
web was not ready to accommodate this
large user base the thousands and
thousands of users and people that were
using the worldwide web project every
day to address this issue uh and make
the worldwide web more scalable he
proposed a couple of
constraints that could help achieve the
goal and these constraints are number
one client server which we still follow
by the way the client server model this
constraint basically emphasizes the
separation of con concerns between the
client and the server the client handles
all the user interface the user
experience while the server manages data
storage and business logic which we also
call as the front end and back end this
separation allows each component to
evolve independently and to improve
scalability that's the first constraint
the second constraint is uniform
interface this constraint simplifies the
overall system architecture by
establishing a standardized way a
standardized way of components different
different components that the web
comprises of to communicate with each
other it also includes uh four subc
constraints which are called resource
identification resource manipulation
through
representation self-descriptive messages
and Hyper media as the engine of
application State we have also sub
constraints under this one the uniform
interface the philosophy of uniform
interface the uniformity provides a
consistent interface across all the
services third one layered system now
this says that the architecture composed
of hierarchical layers and each layer
can only see and interact with the
immediate layer below it and this allows
for better scalability security and the
ability to add intermediate components
like load balancers and prox servers Etc
which we use today to scale our web
applications to cater to millions of
users right and and this happens without
affecting the system's core
functionality now fourth cach cach uh
responses from the server must be
explicitly labeled as the cachable or
non-cashable that's what this constraint
says the server should label different
different responses as whether it should
be cached or not by the client and when
the clients need they can cash the
responses which helps reduce the server
load uh improve Network efficiency and
enhance the user experience by providing
faster response times now fifth one is
stateless now stateless we have already
covered in a much more depth in the
previous video I think it was the HTTP
video uh this basically means that each
request from the client to the server
must contain all the information
necessary to understand the and process
the request the server basically will
not remember what your previous request
was about with each request you have to
include all the information necessary uh
so that the server can identify you and
the server can take your data understand
it and process it that's what stateless
means and the server does not store any
client context between requests and this
in turn improves reliability scalability
and visibility since any server can
handle the request let's say you are
scaling your web application and you
have added two more servers and there is
a load balancer in between which
forwards your traffic depending on
different different algorithm like round
robin etc etc and because of this
stateless constraint all the servers can
process request from the same client
because of the statelessness nature of
the web because all the requests consist
all the information that the server
needs to process the data and the sixth
one which is code on demand this is an
optional one uh which means that servers
can temporarily extend client
functionality by transferring executable
code like JavaScript to the client and
this is only an optional constraint in
rest
architecture because it provides
flexibility to add client side
functionality when we need it uh while
maintaining other constraints and etc
etc this is not something you will see
getting used heavily these six are
basically all the constraints that Roy
Fielding came up with to solve the
problem of scalability in web and later
on Fielding worked with Team Berner Le
and both of them together worked to
increase the scalability of web and and
to standardize their designs and
together they wrote a specification for
the new version of HTTP which we today
know as HTTP 1.1 the first major version
the first standard version of the HTTP
protocol and then in the year 2000 after
the scalability crisis of web was avered
Fielding Roy Fielding named and
described the web's architecture style
in his PhD dissertation and it was
called as rest representational State
transfer which was Roy fielding's PhD
dissertation that was the name that
Fielding gave to his description of the
web architectural style and which today
we know as rest apis and if you go and
search Roy Fielding rest paper you can
directly open this and and read the
first document that was written about
Rest apis by ra fielding and you can get
more insight more context and what uh
LED them to come up with all these
patterns come up with all these Concepts
etc etc right it is a must read if you
are a backend engineer reading this
gives you a lot of context about where
all these Technologies originated from
all these Technologies patterns
standards that we have today okay great
now that brings us to why is it called a
rest API what does it actually mean if
you read the paper that was uh written
by Roy Fielding you'll definitely get
the idea why was he calling it rest
architecture or restful architecture or
rest API but if you want to make it
brief why the name rest why the name
representational State transfer then we
can up with some points number one is
representational the first part of this
name r which means representation this
basically means that resources on the
internet resources on the web which
means data or objects are represented in
a specific
format they have a specific
representation depending on the specific
servers and specific clients and these
representations can be in various
formats it can be in
Json that is the most popular uh
representation format that we have these
days but we also have
XML and we also have HTML so different
different representations depending on
different different context for example
a server to server communication will
depend on the Json based representation
while a server to client based
communication depend on the HTML ml
based communication right that's what
representation means when we are talking
about web's architecture the rest API
architecture the same resource can have
different representation based on the
client's needs so a user for example
let's say we have a user resource which
might have different different fields an
ID field a name field a created at field
etc etc so let's say we have a user
resource a database resource let's
assume so a user resource this can have
different different representation
depending on different different clients
let's say this can be represented as a
Json right for an API client let's say
another server is making a request to
get this object or get this resource
then this can have a Json based
representation but if we want to send
some uh UI data to the browser then we
can represent this as an HTML document
or as some kind of HTML representation
right for the client which is a web
browser so that's what we mean by
representational in the restful
architecture coming back to the second
part state representational state
transfer so what do we mean by state
here State basically refers to the
current condition or attributes of a
particular resource the current property
of a resource the state of the resource
and each resource let's say we had a
user resource here so each resource has
a state that can be transferred between
client and server and the state is
driven by the resource representation so
taking an example let's say we have a uh
e-commerce site let's say we have Amazon
we have Amazon and we have a shopping
cart in the cart we have a couple of
items so a shopping cart State includes
all the items the quantities of the
items and the total price so that we can
call as a state of a particular resource
of a particular module that we have in
our web application that is transferred
between a client and a server with each
API call and the last part which is
transfer representational State transfer
the third part talks about transfer what
does transfer mean so transfer basically
indicates the movement of resource the
movement of resource representations
between client and server so obviously
since we have a client server model the
primary intention of that is sending
data between client and server and the
client and server can exchange different
representations of the same resource we
have a client here and we have a server
here and the transfer of data happens uh
through a common standard which is
HTTP and we have uh different different
methods associated with that which is
get post uh put delete patch options
head etc etc right we have all these
different different uh methods which we
use to send data between client and
server for example when you get a web
page when you uh send a get request to a
server for a web page you are
transferring a repres presentation from
server to client using an common HTTP
method which is get so when we combine
this when we combine all these three
elements uh which is called
representational State transfer or also
known as rest or restful or rest API
this describes an architectural style
where one resources are representated in
different formats we have different
different formats we have J on we have
HTML we have XML etc etc first thing is
resources have different different
formats second the state of these
resources can be transferred between
server and client client and server
first is the format of the resource the
second is the state of the resource
third clients and servers communicate
between each other by sharing these
representations of a resource okay the
representations can be different but the
idea is client and server communicate
with each other using these
representations and third the system
this whole system follows specific
constraints specific constraints to make
the whole workflow more scalable right
which we have already discussed so
that's what we mean by restful API or
rest architecture that's the history
behind uh where and when and how we came
up with this whole architecture this
whole model of representing resources
and transferring resources between
client and servers and different
different formats etc etc right this is
all the theory that you need to
understand on a very high level you
don't need to remember any of it but
this gives you a little bit of context
of where and how we came up with all
these things and where are we currently
let's start with a URL and this is what
a typical high level structure of a URL
looks like know in any website that we
visit this part what we call is the
scheme uh whether it can be HTTP or it
can be https the secure version the
encrypted version then we have the
authority or the domain it can also have
a subdomain but in this case we have the
main domain which is sly.
XYZ then we have the resource or the
path so this part uh uh is called the
resource that we are trying to access
and this symbol the forward slash symbol
represents a hierarchical relationship
between different resources and then we
have the query parameters which we use
in usually get apis to pass some kind of
key value pairs to give more information
to server about uh some kind of filters
parameters etc etc then we have
fragments uh this section usually uh
navigates you to a particular section of
a web page if this is present in the URL
when you first time navigate to a web
page if you have a fragment then the
browser Scrolls you to that part of the
page okay so this is what a typical uh
website URL looks like now we since we
are talking about apis and best apis
starting from this what would a an API
URL or an API route will look like so we
can start from this we will obviously
have the scheme so let's imagine we have
the encrypted version the secure version
htps then we will have a subdomain so
I'm talking about the industri standard
right this is not a rule uh this is more
of a standard or best practices that
most companies follow uh when they are
implementing when they're creating their
backends so usually it starts with a
subdomain of the main with a subdomain
of API so API dot let's say example
example.com okay this is the subdomain
part subdomain part then we have
versioning most apis implement or follow
some kind of versioning pattern and
usually through routes so this will
follow something like V1 or V2 etc etc
then we reach the path or the resource
that we are trying to access so let's
imagine it is a it is an API which is
like good reads if you are aware of good
read it's a platform where there are a
lot of books there are a lot of authors
and books are associated with authors
you can provide your reviews feedbacks
etc etc it's a whole community about
readers and authors and books Etc if
this API is of good RS then an apaa
which fetches all the list of books will
have something of a structure like this
so then we write the name of the
resource so book now the first rule is
in an API when you're designing a route
when you're designing an API in the path
segment whatever resource that you you
are providing whatever resource your
client is trying to access or whatever
resource the backend is serving that
should always be in the plural form it
is a standard that all the resources in
your path segment of the URL should be
of plural form so ideally it should be
books okay then we have this API uh
which has the subdomain api. example.com
SL we have the versioning here and then
we have books this is an API to list all
the books to fetch the list of all books
similarly we can have another API so
let's say we remove this this this let's
say we have another AP which fetches a
single book so up to this point we have
bit constant right uh of course the we
can have different different versions of
the same API but for the sake of this
example let's imagine up to this point
we are in the version one only and this
part is constant we will have the scheme
https then we will have the subdomain
api. example.com then we'll have the
version in which is the V1 but in the
second API we want to fetch the
information for a single book so what
will the path look like now there is one
mistake here which most people do is
since we are fetching the information of
single book uh people make this as a
singular now right they make this slash
book or then whatever the book ID etc
etc you should not do that because um
even though you are fetching the
information of a single book but the
resource that it is concerned about this
resource which is the book resource that
is represented as a plural noun when we
are dealing with path segments in the
URL so even if this is about a single
book we have to put we have to make it
plural here so it will still be books
then we have the ID now uh since we are
talking about URLs one thing that you
have to uh keep in mind when you're are
designing apis are the readability the
representation of URLs in browsers or
different different client environments
couple of things that you have to
remember is you should not put spaces or
under scores etc etc these characters in
a URL whether it can be a uh slug or
whether it can be an ID know whatever
part that you're dealing with for a
route you should not put spaces or
underscores in a URL the thumb roll is
if you have a phrase which has spaces
and you want to put that into the URL
let's say uh we have this API and we
want to fetch the information of a
single book and we want to fet the
information using the slug of the book
now slug is basically the name or some
property of the book let's say the name
of this book is Harry Potter the name of
this book is Harry Potter now the slug
of this book will be a human readable
representation of some property of that
resource which is ideal to put inside a
URL
which means first thing that we do to
convert this into a slug is we make all
of this a small case even though we can
put Capital case but because the URL
will be traveling to different different
environments it will travel to different
server environments different client
environments different operating system
we don't want to mess with the case
mismatch etc etc right so first thing
that we'll do is we make both of this as
smaller is the first change is the part
okay this is the first change second
every time we have a space we will
replace that with a hyphen now we have
the final slug which is Harry Potter and
now we can put this into a URL so/ book
SL Harry Potter one thing that I
mentioned a while bag is I said whenever
we use this character the forward SL
character in a URL uh uh in an API route
in a path segment this means there is a
hierarchical relationship between these
resources so for example this API this
says that we have a resource a
collection of resource which are called
books in our server in our database or
wherever your storage is and that is the
first level of hierarchy the second
level of hierarchy is we want to access
one particular resource from that
collection of resource that resides in
our database or some kind of storage so
this is what I meant whenever we use the
path segment you have to uh think of
this as a hierarchical relationship
between different resources okay so I
think that's pretty much all the primer
about URLs uh that we need to talk about
right now we'll of course explore more
about how to design your routes in
different different apis
when we get to the demo part okay so
moving on another important concept that
we have when we are talking about restas
is em potency this is a very important
theoretical concept uh of course it has
a practical implication but the concept
of item potency basically means the
property of certain operations in which
performing the same action multiple
times has the same effect as performing
it once
which means an action which you have
performed using an API call it does not
matter how many times you perform that
action the effect the side effect the
change that happens in that environment
Remains the Same it does not matter how
many times you perform that action
that's what we mean by em potency so in
this context in the context uh where we
are talking about rest apis item potency
basically means it does not matter how
many times the client performs a
particular request the outcome the
result of that request in the server
environment Remains the Same so even if
I call an API once or I call the API
thousand times the outcome of that the
result of that should be the same if we
call a particular API or a particular
action is item poent now as you already
know when talking about different
different actions that we can perform
using API calls we come to the concept
of HTTP methods and in the previous
video of HTTP we have already discussed
this in depth what are the different
types of methods how they work what are
the properties Etc ET so we have around
five major kinds of methods that we use
to handle different different data
operations okay we have get we have post
we have put we have patch and we have
delete okay these are the five major
methods we have other methods also head
and options etc etc which um head is
used to patch the headers information
and options is used to uh options is
used in our course flow to find out
whether the origin is allowed or not etc
etc right but majorly these are the five
kinds of methods that we use for data
transfer between clients and servers now
relating the concept of emut see two s
methods uh gives us a lot of insights
into which method should we use in which
context okay now the get call which we
usually use to fetch some information
from the server now this method is used
to retrieve data from a server and it is
em potent a get method or a get action
on a server is considered as item poent
because it does not matter how many
times you perform a get request you will
get the same outcome right let's say we
in the previous example we are fetching
a list of books we fetching a list of
books so it does not matter how many
times you call this API you'll get a
list of books and now you must be
thinking what if uh while you're are
making these API calls someone else
creates another book and the result
changes the response of the API changes
in the subsequent calls of the G and and
that's true but that is not what we
consider when we are talking about item
poent item poent basically means from
the client using an API call what side
effect can you cause in the server and
whether that side effect is different
with each API call or that remains same
during the first API call or the 1,000
API call okay now and because of that
reason the get call is considered item
poent it does not matter how many times
you fetch some information you do not
make any change with your API call in
the server environment okay it is just a
fetch operation that's why the get is
called an item Buton method similarly
the patch method and the put method
these two methods that we generally use
to update some data in the server to
update a particular resource or a part
of a resource we use patch when we up we
want to update a part of a resource
let's say a single single field or two
three fields of a resource in the server
in that case we use patch we use put
when we want to completely replace the
representation of resource in the server
using the client payload so let's say we
have a user object in the server it has
ID it has name it has created at etc etc
and for an update operation if we want
to update the name of the user if you
want to use the p method then we can
just send the name field with the new
value of the name and the server will
handle it accordingly it will just
update the name but using put method
what it does we have to send both the ID
the name the created all the fields in
that payload so that the server can take
that payload and completely replace it
with whatever instance of that user
object the server has currently now it
is true that um most of the time put and
Patch is used interchangeably and that
is fine that is fine to some extent uh
as long as you using your API internally
but let's imagine you are building some
kind of public API in that case you have
to implement your API specs in a way
that sticks to the standard as much as
it can so that other people other
Engineers who want to integrate your API
do not get confused because they assume
that you are following a standard but
you are not so if you are using put when
you should be using patch then that
gives some kind of wrong assumption and
it might be a confusing situation but
again it does not cause as much of a
harm because obviously from the behavior
of the a people can tell whether it is a
patch operation happening or I put
operation but yes uh you should always
try to stick to the standard stick to
the semantic standard that the rest a
offers so if you want to update a
particular resource partially then use
patch if you want to completely replace
the representation of a resource then
use put okay now patch and put are also
called as emed because let's say we are
updating the name of the user with a new
value let's say the previous name of the
user was a and we want to replace it
with the new payload which is B okay so
we make our first API call and we send
this payload okay and the name of the
user becomes from A to B that's the side
effect that we caused using our API in
the first API call what happens in the
second API call the name of the user is
already B but we make the same API call
with the same payload now from B it
again changes to B okay now that
continues it does not matter how many
times you all that API it can be
thousand it can be million but the
result will be same after each operation
the state of the user Remains the Same
the name is still B you are not causing
different side effects with each API
call that's the reason patch andp put
any kind of update operation with the
same payload will obviously be item now
we have ruled out get and patch and put
as uted methods next up is delete now
what do you think delete is whether it
is item button or not now imagine again
we have this user object uh which has an
ID name and created at field and we make
a delete API call to the server and we
deleted this user this user does not
exist that is the result of the first
API call what happens in the second API
call you make the same request to delete
the API uh to delete the user which has
the ID as one okay you made the same API
call in the first payload with the user
ID one and you are making the same API
call again with the user ID on you want
to delete this user in the second API
call since this user is already deleted
the server checks your payload it checks
whether the user exists or not and it
sends you an error that this user does
not exist it sends you a 404 error since
you are trying to perform some action on
an entity which does not exist that's
the reason you are getting a 404 error
but did you cause any side effect in the
second AP go you did not because in the
first API call you deleted the user in
the second API call nothing really
happened the server just checked whether
the user exists or not and it send you
an error but nothing really changed no
state of the entity changed in the
server it it had no side effects that's
the reason it does not matter how many
times you call this delete API call
you can call it a million times you'll
get the same error million times that
this user does not exist you only made
the change in the first API call and
that's the reason delete is also
considered as an item poent method at
last we reach post now this is the only
method in the HTTP semantics which is
considered as a nonm poent method
because when we use a post request
usually the post request is used when we
want to create a new resource or a new
entity in the server so taking from our
previous example which was a book API if
you want to create a new book we want to
add a new book to our inventory in that
case we'll send the name of the book and
some kind of description some kind of um
weight Dimensions Etc different
different properties of the book and we
will take this payload put it in the
body and we send this to the server in a
post call and the server receives it it
takes the payload and it performs some
kind of database operation and in it
inserts that uh entity into the database
it creates a new book now that's that's
what happened in the first AP call in
the second API call let's imagine you
made the same payload with the same name
description ion bit Dimensions etc etc
you just took the Cur of that request
and you executed that Cur again you made
the same API call again what happens now
there is a chance
that um in this API the name has to be
unique if that is one condition that
your server is following or your
database is following then you might get
an error which is the name cannot be
duplicate ET
but for the sake of this example and it
for the sake of real world scenario it
is often the case that names can be
duplicated right multiple books can have
the same name right the that's that's
the reason we differentiate between
different books from their IDs not from
the names so that's the reason uh when
you make the same API call in the second
time what happens the server takes your
payload it performs the same operation
and it inserts it into the database now
you have the second book with the same
information right but with a different
ID IDs are usually generated at the
database level uh whether uu ID or some
kind of Serial value 1 2 3 4 ET IDs are
generated at the database level that's
the reason you can have multiple books
with the same kind of properties name
description weight Dimensions etc etc
but the IDS will be different that's the
reason an error does not occur that's
the second API call and this is the
pattern with each API call you are
creating a new book and when you if you
call this API a thousand times you'll
have a thousand new books now what we
discussed what is the property of what
is the condition of idency the side
effects that you cause in the server
should not be different with each
request right but it's the opposite
happening for the Post calls right with
each API call you are creating a new
book the side effects are changing and
that's the reason post request post
methods are are called nonm poent
Methods now one more thing about post is
whenever we have a noncured operation an
operation an action that does not fall
under any of the methods that is defined
by HTTP spec right it is not a fetch
operation it is not an update operation
not a create operation not a delete
operation it does not fall under any of
the methods in that scenario because of
the existence of scenarios like these
the s spec the rest AP spec has made the
post method as open-ended which means
whenever you find yourself in a scenario
where you cannot put some action
some uh action in any of the existing
methods then you can put that under the
post call in the post method so let's
imagine we have an API which uh says we
which is like send email okay we have
this AP and when we call this we can
send an email to a client so let's say
the payload the body of this API call
looks something like this target is some
email address right and when we make
this API call the server takes it and
extracts the
payload the target email and sends the
email that is basically the
functionality of this API now the point
that I'm trying to make here is what
HTTP method that you would assign to
this action or this API because it say
send email but is this a fetch operation
it's not right it is some kind of action
we want to tell the server that do
perform this action whether it is a
create operation it's not it's not an
update or delete operation either that's
the reason it is called a custom action
in the HTTP or rest AP terminology so
whenever we have scenarios like is
whenever we have custom actions the
operations or API calls which we cannot
categorize under any of the Curr
operations those are the situations that
we can make use of the post method which
is meant to be used for custom actions
as for the rest TP specification okay
and that's pretty much all about HTTP
methods uh when we are talking about
rest
apis now let's move on to some demo
right
how exactly do you start with your API
design how do you actually design the
interface for your API the interface
that other clients whether it is server
based clients or browser based clients
any kind of clients can uh talk to can
interact the first thing if you are a
backend engineer the first thing before
you start coding before you write any of
the business Logic the first thing you
should do
uh while creating an API is designing
the interface for the API the interface
should be intuitive it should be
delightful to use and it should not be
vague it should follow most of the
standards of uh rest apis and the reason
for that is the reason for following
standards the reason for
following restful standards is to
eliminate uh confus usion eliminate
assumptions or any kind of human related
errors in your whole workflow what that
means is let's say you are designing
your apis and you did not follow any of
the standards and uh whenever you should
have used put you used uh post and you
used delete operation to perform fetch
operation ET ET you messed up the AP
interface completely intentionally now
as a result someone the consumer whoever
that is any engineer who is integrating
your API the only way the only way for
them to find out all the behavior of
your API starting from the successful
Behavior and the error behavior and how
the payloads are structured how the data
is structured and what uh method to call
ET the complete API integration workflow
for them to figure it out completely
they have only two options they have to
either read your code if it is open
source or it is someone within your
organization who has access to your code
or they have to try out different
methods and see as a result of the
deoration if it is expected or not and
you can see that that that's a lot of
room for error a lot of room for
confusions and assumption etc etc now
having a common standard and following a
particular standard in your workflows
especially when you're designing API
interfaces gives you and all the
consumers of your apis the advantage
that they do not have to do any kind of
guess work most of the behaviors are
already defined in the standard so
assuming that assuming the standards are
uh at least 80% followed in most cases
the the effort and the time to integrate
the API decreases a lot when you follow
standards and uh there are less bugs
there are less confusions and there are
less synup calls with the uh whoever is
integrating your apas Etc ET because all
the uh you have been following all the
standards the documentations are in
place you have an interactive API uh
playground etc etc now there is almost
no room for errors or confusions right
that is the advantage of following
standards following best practices so
that the creator of the API and the
consumer of the API already have some
some kind of knowledge that this API
will have these kinds of behaviors and
there is no guess for involved there the
first thing what is the first thing that
you should do as a backend engineer when
you are creating an API you should start
with is from your UI design interface it
could be uh figma or any other kind of
software that your designer or your
product team uses to build wireframes or
uh user stories etc etc now that's the
place you should start with when you're
designing an API because when you follow
the wireframe you have an idea that how
the end user not the frontend engineer
the engineer F consumer API will
interact with it you but you will have
an idea that how the end user the users
who are going to use your platform are
going to interact with data in general
so uh usually this is how it works you
have your users they interact with your
platform the platform is built by your
front end engineer and your front-end
engineer consumes whatever API that you
have built and you in turn interact with
different different databases Etc as
like you know the DB level so in a way
when you look at the W frames the
designs of how the users are going to
interact with your platform you have a
very good understanding of how the user
the first level of consumption are
related to the last the low level of uh
consumption which is the database right
and forgetting about all this
middlemen that comes into play whenever
uh we have the whole SAS platform Etc
once you have the clarity on how your
users are related to your data and
that's an excellent point to start your
actual API interface design because at
this point you will find out what are
the resources so since we are talking
about restas the first important concept
the first important
entity uh that we should cover is
resources now the resources are
basically any any kind of nouns that you
can identify from your wireframes or by
talking to your clients by understanding
the requirements after you understood
all the requirements whether by um from
the whether from the wireframes or from
talking to different people the product
people or client people etc etc once you
have the requirements from those
requirements whatever noun you can find
okay of of course this is an
oversimplified uh definition of what are
resource in a backend workflow but
mostly this rule works this is a kind of
a thumb rule so whatever nouns you can
find from there are your resources so
imagine it is a uh project you are
working on a project which is a project
management SAS a project management
platform okay uh something like uh jira
or linear etc etc you working on a
product which is similar to J linear
which is a project management platform
now after going through all the
wireframes all the figma designs and
after talking to your clients your
product people you can analyze your
requirements and you can find out some
of the nouns that come up in those
requirements what could be some of the
nouns the obvious ones are since this is
a project management platform it will
have projects right this is the first
noun what is the second noun your users
obviously it's a project management
platform it will have users users are
another noun then you can have
organizations users can be part of
different different organization so that
is another uh resource that you can come
up with then each project will have
tasks associated with it there is
another noun then uh task can be um
organized with different different tags
so tags are another noun similarly as
you can see the pattern once you have
analyzed your figma designs you can
easily come up with these resources and
you can note it down and once you have
all the resources noted down you have
figured out uh what are the different
different resources that your back end
that your platform will have okay the
nouns the top level entities after this
uh usually you jump into the database
schema right since uh this video is only
about the rest DPA side of it which
usually comes after you have done with
your DB schema designs the next video of
course deals with uh all the DV schema
designs and different different concepts
of databases so we'll skip this part how
you design your DV schema how you um
interact with your databases all the
concepts surrounding Etc ET we'll leave
this for the next video we'll focus only
on the rest of part this is what the
workflow looks like once you have
identified all the resources from your
fig designs you jump into your DB schema
design and after you done with your DB
schema design you get to your API
interface design part since we are not
talking about uh the DB schema design
and all in this video we'll just do a
very quick uh schema design so that we
can continue to the rest API phase of
the API design workflow since we have
skipped the database schema design part
which we'll cover in the next video
Let's imagine you are done with your
databas schema design and you have these
three tables okay uh since it's a
project management platform you started
with these three tables you have the
organization table where you will keep
track of all the organizations that
exist in your platform then you have
project uh what are all the projects
that exist within an organization then
you have task uh inside task you will
keep uh track of what are all the tasks
that are created inside a project so for
the sake of this demo and for the sake
of this video uh we are building the API
interface for a project management
platform and we will get started with
this schema design we have an
organization table we have a project
table have task table with this we will
start our API design now the next thing
to do we have already uh gone through
our figma designs and understood all the
requirements we have come up with all
the nouns all the resources that we have
to create and using the resources we
have created all the database schemas
and now we have database tables now we
have we already know the resources of
our platform now we need to create apis
for that the next thing to do since we
already have this schema the next thing
to do is finding out what are the
actions that a client a typical client
who will interact with your API needs to
perform on our server what are the
actions and you can get started uh with
some template actions using our crud API
endpoints right uh a typical resource
will have fetchall uh get a single
resource update delete create etc etc
right using that you will you will list
out all the actions that you need to uh
the users need to perform using your API
which we usually call is CR operations
create read update and delete and after
you know all the actions you'll jum jump
into the API interface design part and
for the API interface design part we'll
use this Tool uh which is called
insomnia uh it's an alternative to
postman it is an alternative to postman
but it has lesser features and it's a
lighter in weight as compared to postman
so we'll make use of this tool to uh
design the interface of our API what
should the API of this platforms look
like right remember we are designing the
interface for this API which means that
uh we are designing how clients who are
going to consume our API who are going
to integrate our API what the apis will
look like how they will interact with
etc etc right the interface point we are
designing the interface Point not the
execution point which includes writing
whatever programming language that
you're writing your server in etc etc
your actual business logic
your database interactions Etc ET we are
not going to cover that in this part we
are only going to be concerned about the
design of your API okay with that uh
let's start so we have identified three
uh major resources in our API which are
uh organization project and task right
so we have to design API surrounding
these three resources starting with
organization and we have also identified
what are the actions that clients need
to perform with our a so according to
those we have come up with five
different kinds of actions for
organization uh create organization get
all organizations get a single
organization and update organization
delete organization etc etc right so
let's start how the AP will look like I
will create a new HTTP request so the
first let's design the get all
organizations AP so it is it will be a
get API because we are doing a fetch
operation right now the next thing is
we'll write the URL of our server now
this is subject to change uh when you go
to production uh the domain will change
the scheme will change from HTTP to
https and since I am running it in Local
Host the scheme is HTTP and the domain
is Local Host and my server is running
on Port
3000 that's that and since it is just a
demo we have not uh integrated
versioning here but usually uh apis will
have some kind of versions here/ V1 then
the actual path will come but here we
are not doing versioning as of now so we
are done with the URL part now comes the
important part the actual route the
actual path segment which is going to um
identify what is that that we are trying
to fetch from the server since it is an
API so let's rename this to list
organizations right
list all organization so this is what it
looks like right as I already said uh we
don't put Capital case in the path
segment so we write organization and we
have already mentioned that uh it should
always be plural the resource part so it
will be organizations this is what a
typical list uh resource API looks like
you have the domain you have the
versioning if it exists and then uh the
resource name in plural so this is
ideally the list API and when we call
this we are getting the empty response
okay the empty response so let's jump
into the second API uh which is the
create organization AP then we'll have a
better idea about how the get one works
right create organization and this will
be a post operation because we are
creating a resource in the server right
it's a create operation that's why we
are using the method post uh let's just
copy this and paste this now here our
URL looks pretty much the same for list
organizations and for create
organization and the reason for that is
the server differentiates between these
two API calls using the HTTP method if
it is a post method then this route goes
towards the controller which handles
creating an organization and if it is a
get call with the same URL it goes to
the controller which deals with listing
all the organizations right so this is
what a typical create operation for a
particular resource looks like uh we
have the as usual the servers address
and Slash the name of the resource in
plural form okay now this is a post call
so we have to attach the payload the
data that the server needs to create an
organization so if we look at the
organization schema we have to exclude
these three Fields these are database
handled Fields right the ID the created
it and updated it these are handled from
the server side so we exclude these from
the payload now these three Fields the
name the status and the description
these three Fields can be passed from
the client side using a pay Lo so let's
pass these three name status and
description name will provide as Arc one
status since it's a Json payload we have
to wrap all the fields in double codes
so second is status status let's say is
active and the last one is description
is some some description right and these
are payload and when we run this we get
this right we have have an ID which is
created in the server s side and we have
the created at which is also created in
the server site and then we have the
name status and description which we had
passed in the payload that is provided
here so this is the first thing that we
should notice here in a typical post API
call uh after calling the response is
usually 2011 which we return when we
create a resource in the server if a new
resource is created cre then we return
the status code AS 2011 which means U
created okay and then we return the
newly created entity as it is in the
success response that's why we have
received the newly created organization
here okay this is what the typical post
interaction looks like now going back to
our earlier list organization when we
call this now now we are getting the
entry the organization that we created
the organization that we created just
now using the post call okay here the
status code is 200 because 200 uh we
return 200 status code when it is a
successful response 2011 is when we
create something but 20 is when it is
just a success response we are sending
some kind of data etc etc right
this another thing to focus here is
What's Happening Here uh we have a data
field we have a total field we have a
page field we have total Pages etc etc
and this thing is called pagination the
terminology is pagination and why do we
actually need pagination the need for
pagination pagination is basically a
technique uh which is used in server
side when uh we are doing some kind of
API call where a list of a particular
resources returned in this case we are
requesting a list of organizations
whenever we have an API call like this
which returns a list of some kind of
resource and depending on the
requirement we use this technique we
implement this technique which is called
pagination what it does it does not
return all the resources that exist in
the database in the server side in that
particular request right it returns a
particular portion of the data in the
response okay and since at this point we
only have one organization so I cannot
uh show you the difference but we'll
create a couple of organization we'll
see how the pagination works right so
let's understand the theory first so
this is the this is why we use
pagination if we have a lot of data in
the database and when the client makes
an API call so we only return a
particular portion of that data in the
response so that first thing Json
serialization and deserialization as we
have already covered in the previous uh
some video that is a heavy operation
right so if we let's say send a,
organization in the response so
serializing a th000 organizations into a
payload which is transferable across uh
internet is a resource heavy task right
it can introduce some kind of delay in
our API it can have some kind of
performance impact so that is one reason
the second is if the server takes a
little longer to send the response then
the client uh the whatever the front end
platform that is requesting that is
using this API that will also have some
kind of perceived delay and the user the
end user who is using the platform they
will notice the difference right they
will notice there is some kind of 3
seconds and 4 seconds of delay that is
happening because the client is fetching
a thousand organizations in the list API
call even though even though the on the
first look on the first look when
someone is using the platform they will
only see let's say a 10 or 20
organization right if they want to see
more organization they'll obviously have
to scroll right now because of that kind
of scenario people have come up with
this technique called page nation in
page Nation what happens in the initial
call you return some portion of data
usually from the first and sorted by
some parameter let's say the created
parameter you return the latest 10
organization in the first API call right
then when the user the end user clicks
on page two or if it's an infinite
scroll Scrolls down you make another API
call and you say this part I already
have give me the next portion this
portion of the data right and then you
take this and you show it to the user
similarly when the user goes on page
three you ask for this portion and you s
this data and this is how it works at at
once you only fetch let's say 20 or 30
organizations and show it to the user so
the user is also not overwhelmed network
is not overwhelmed and the client in
server perform better and that is the
advantage of pation and this is often
used whenever we are implementing some
kind of list API so in this case we are
listing organizations right that's why
we have implemented pagination here now
the second thing to notice here is what
are the fields that we are returning
from in a pag response the first part is
data whatever portion of the data we
have to return that we return in the
data field the second is total now this
total field Returns the total count of
all the organizations that is in the
database and using this information the
client can s some kind of metadata to
the user that um you have around 50
organization but at this page you are
only viewing 10 right it can show some
kind of UI like this 10 or 50 something
something so for representation purpose
for UI purpose we return a field which
which uh shows the total count of all
the resources that exist in our database
which is independent of what portion of
the data we are returning it is
independent of the page response next is
we return the Page Field uh which page
which portion of data that the server is
is returning for this response this
response which page it is associated
with which portion it is right we have
to assign some kind of number some kind
of identifier the portion of the data
that we are asking from the server
that's the reason we call it a page and
in this the server is saying this
response is for page one you are doing
page one then we return total Pages how
many pages in total there are and we can
use this to show some kind of nice UI
interactions or uh if it's an infinite
scroll we can check for each time we are
making the API call we can check whether
uh the page and the total Pages if they
are both same then we stop making the
API call so because now that we know
that uh we have reached the end of the
pages right so this also provides some
nice functionalities it helps the front
end make some decisions about whether to
make the next API call or not etc etc
this is what a typical paginated
response looks like now let's go to the
create a and create a few more
organizations right let say organization
2 oration three organization 4 oration
five okay we've created Five
organizations and when we go to the list
API and we call this we're getting all
five now that we have
around five organizations how do we
access let's see how the pageon actually
works and how the client can ask for
different different portions of the data
using different different parameters
since it is a get call the only way we
can send data from client to server some
kind of payload data is using query
parameters now the server takes two kind
of parameters for controlling how the
pagination works the first one is limit
limit basically means what is the count
of data that you want in each response
since we have five entries five
organizations what if we do limit is two
each time we only want two organizations
right the second parameter is page which
portion of the data that you want by
default if we don't send page and limit
the server should and remember since we
are in designing the interface try to
focus what are the points uh the server
should Implement right if the client
does not send anything in limited page
the server should set some kind of
default values for these so by default
the server sets the value of page as one
if the client does not send any kind of
uh parameter in the page parameter same
way the limit will be set to something
like 10 or 20 if the client does not
send it but here we are explicitly
sending it so let's make this request
what happens when we do limit two and
when we make this request the server
returned us two organizations sorted by
created at know the latest organizations
that's why we are getting organization
five and organization four because
that's the order that we created we
first created organization 4 then
organization 5 that's why we are getting
in this order okay second in total the
server is returning how many entries are
present in the database yes we have five
organizations but we are returning two
okay because the client has passed the
limit as two then which portion of the
data that the server is returning which
is which page the server is returning
which is page one and how many pages are
there in total there are three pages
because if the limit is two and the
total number of organizations are five
then then to send all the data to
clients the server has to make three
pages in The First page there will be
two entries in the second page there
will be two entries in the last page
there will be one entry okay that's how
pation works so when we do page as two
and we keep the limit as two and then we
make this request this is what we get we
get organization 3 and organization two
in the response basically we have this
whole data portion where we have let's
say uh organization 5 4 3 2 and one when
we make page as one we get organization
five and organization 4 basically this
portion when we make Pages two we get
this portion right three and two and at
the last when we'll make page three we
should ideally get only the organization
one because in the in the last page
there is only one
entry let's change this to page three
and we got organization one and single
response because we are asking give us
the page three the last portion of the
data so the total is five the current
page is three and the total pages is
three okay these are basically the
metadata about what is the current state
of pation and this is how the client can
and the client should interact with your
apis right you should allow for a limit
parameter and a page parameter so that
the client can uh conditionally and
programmatically access different
different portions of the data so that's
pretty much all about pagination how the
server should Implement pagination okay
a typical list API also has other
parameters let's say let's get rid of
this okay let's get rid of these we
don't want to uh look at page Nation
anymore and when we send this we get all
the five organization because by default
the server sets the limit s 10 or some
random value because even if the client
does not send anything in the limit
parameter the server should set some
number as limit and page one as default
parameters right now let's talk about
sort in a typical list API we a server
should also support sorting and this is
how it looks like we can pass one
parameter for defining by which field we
want to sort by okay it is typically
written as sord by and here we can
provide the name of the field that we
want to sort by so here let's say we
want to sort by name we are saying we
want to sort by name okay and when we
send this you're getting oration 5 4 3 2
okay no difference as of now now let's
add another parameter which is called
sort order
and here let's send ascending and when
we do that here as you can see by
default the server was returning all the
organizations in the descending order so
by now you should have realized this
rule the rule that the server should
ideally ideally take as many as it can s
defaults and by S defaults I mean it
should not depend on the client to send
obvious fields for example in a list API
by default even if the client does not
send anything we still got a response
right we did not get any validation
error that you are missing this
parameter you're missing the page
parameter um that made our whole
experience way better because we did not
have to pass obvious Fields obvious
fields are such as page if the client
does not pass the any explicit page the
server should set the default pages one
similarly for limit if limit is not
passed you should set a default limit
either 10 or 20 something okay same way
even if the client does not do any kind
of manual or explicit sorting the server
should do some kind of sorting by
default so that the response of the data
does not change between different
different API calls if you don't sort by
some parameter in the server before
sending the response each time the
client makes an API call it will get the
response in a random order because the
database does not store and entries in
any kind of sequence you have to
explicitly do sorts that's the reason by
default if you're creating an API
especially a list API you should have
some kind of default sort parameters so
by default what uh we usually do we take
the created at field take the created at
field and we sort by this field and sort
by what order we sort by descending
order now this is the natural state the
default state of sort even if the client
does not pass anything because it's a
obvious response right we want to list
all the entities all the resources in
the descending order of their creation
basically all the latest entries right
that is a natural thing to assume from
the server side that's the reason this
is considered a s default when it comes
to sorting scenarios in list apis but if
the client does want to do some kind
kind of explicit setting the server
should also support two parameters for
sorts one is sort by by which field of
the resource that you want to sort by it
can be name it can be status it can be
ID Etc it depends on your implementation
but it should have some uh fields from
the resource entry same way uh we should
take another parameter which is called
sort order what order the client wants
the sort to happen in by default again
even if the client passes a sort by
field you will still have to set the
default that sort order if not passed
you should set it as descending that is
the reason when we did not pass any sort
order we still got our data our response
sorted by name in descending order
because descending is the default state
of sort order that the server sets even
if the client does not send any sort
orders but if the client sends ascending
as sort order then the server takes that
into account it takes the field it sorts
names in ascending order that's why we
got organization 1 2 3 4 5 in the
ascending order this is how sorting is
implemented in a typical list API we
have covered page naations we have
covered sorting there is one last thing
that is usually supported in a list API
which is called filtering so let's
remove this and and what filtering means
is um even if it's a list API the client
wants to filter that list by some
parameters right so let's say let's go
and create an organization in the body
we see organization as six and in the
status instead of active we do archived
and we create this and this is created
and we got a 2011 response now we go to
list and when we send this we are
getting this or oration six the latest
one right and the status is archived now
what if the client has some kind of
button some kind of switch using which
the user can filter the list by saying I
only want all the organizations whose
statuses are active or whose statuses
are archived basically some kind of
filter functionality and this is how we
add support for filteration in a typical
list API so so we take the name of the
field uh so let's say the client wants
to filter by status so we add a
parameter which called status and inside
this the client can pass what is the
status that it wants to filter by so if
we pass archived and when we send this
we only get the list of all the
organizations whose status is archived
same way if you pass active and when we
send this we only got all the
organizations which has the status as
active and this is called filter okay
and is just one field we can also filter
by other fields so let's say uh we add
another parameter and the filter is name
one the list of all the organizations
whose name is let's say or and when we
send this we are getting only one
response because um in this scenario in
this example we only have one
organization which has the name r for
and that's the reason the API is
returning this okay so with that we have
covered pagination filtering and sorting
all the features that a typical list API
should have okay now moving on let's
create an update API create a new
request and it is a patch request right
the thing is I have personally not used
used a put implementation of an update
APA as much because usually what we do
we take some fields of a resource of an
entity and we want to update those we
never want to replace the whole entity
with a payload that is passed from the
client okay uh it it was usually a
practice when we were building MPS or
multi-page applications but in the
single page applications where the data
is mostly Json heavy we usually pass
partial fields of a resource and we only
want to update those fields so mostly
you will see patch getting used for
update appear instead of put and that is
usually best practice because um if it's
partial Fields then patch conveys that
semantic meaning in a better way as
compared to put which is a little
confusing uh but mostly developers use
put and Patch interchangeably so try to
stick to the standards uh you patch
whenever you are updating partial Fields
oft a resource okay it's a patch request
and we have to uh provide the servers
URL so the servers URL is this one paste
it here organizations now which
organization that we want to update so
this is where a dynamic parameter comes
into play we have already explored what
are Dynamic parameters etc etc and our
routing video so for now we'll just go
ahead and use it so Dynamic parameter is
usually uh some kind of string that we
can arbitrarily pass so let's fetch the
list and let's say we want to update
this we want to update the status of
organization 6 so let's copy the ID and
we take the ID and let's rename this to
date organization okay and as usual this
is the server's address we have the path
which is the plural form of the resource
organizations and after this we write to
the slash we paste the idid of the
organization and this is a valid route
for a patch API con okay we want to
update a single organization that's why
we are passing the ID of the
organization in the dynamic parameter
now the pass request takes a body and
we'll send a Json inside the Json want
to update the status of the organization
and the status is the existing status is
archived we want to make get active Okay
and let's call this and we call this we
are getting the organization six and the
status is active we are successfully
updated it the updated the value of the
status field and when we go to the list
API call and we call this we are getting
the status is active for organization 6
now uh the typical response for an
update or a patch API call the success
response is uh the client sends the
payload in the body and the server sends
a 200 response since it did not create
any resource it is a successful API call
that's why it is sending 200 the
response the success response and in the
response we are sending the updated data
of the organization okay this is what
the typical practice looks like for a
patch IPI call now similarly what if we
want to fetch the information of a
single organization we want to patch the
information so that's why it'll be a get
call so let's first copy copy this and
create a new request let's rename this
to get okay get AR and this is a get
call and let's paste this one and
getting the information of a single
organization and updating the
information of a single organization and
deleting a single organizations mostly
what you will see all these three apis
the get update and delete for aing
single organization the route will look
similar we'll have the server address
we'll have the path parameter with the
plural form of the resource and with a
slash with a forward slash we'll have
the ID in the dynamic parameters place
okay this is what the route will look
like and since it's a get call we uh
don't pass any body or anything and we
can just execute it and we got the
information of the organization we have
passed the ID of the organization 6 and
we got the organization six with status
code 200 because it is just a successful
response we did not create anything we
just fetched information okay at last we
have a delete call we want to delete an
organization so let's uh create an HTTP
request and rename this to Arc and the
method is delete let's paste this as I
said the get call update call and delete
call of a single organization apis will
look similar the route will look similar
the only thing that will differentiate
them is the method whether it is a get
method whether it is a patch method or
it is a delete method okay and we are
not sending anybody we are just sending
the ID of the organization in the
dynamic parameter and we execute this
and when we execute this we do not get
anything uh the response is empty but we
got a different status code which is
which is
204 which means no content the server is
saying that whatever uh operation that
you're trying to do it was successful
that's why the status code starts with
200 series right 200 series all the
codes in the 200 series are success
responses whatever you're trying to do
you trying to delete a resource that was
successful but there is no content I can
send you because it is a delete
operation and it is successful you
successfully deleted the organization
there is no information about the
organization that I can send you that's
what the server is saying that's why we
did not get any response in the response
of the delete API call and this is the
usual practice whenever we have a delete
API call uh we send an empty response
with status code 204 and now when we go
back and we get the list organization we
are getting the organization from
organization 5 because we deleted the
organization six and what happens uh
when we come to the get call the get
single organization API call and we run
this we are getting organization not
found as an error message and in the
status code in the status code we are
getting 404 so this is an ideal use case
for status 404 which basically says that
you are requesting a particular entity
you are requesting a particular entity a
particular resource which has the ID
this one and that resource does not
exist in the server since we have
already deleted this that does not exist
in the server that's why we are wrting
returning error code of 404 which means
resource not pound okay but in the list
API call we do not get any error even if
there are no organizations in the list
it is empty we still do not get an error
because in list API call we are not
requesting for a particular resource we
are requesting a list list of the
resource right a list of organizations
that is the reason we never send four
or4 responses in list API calls a 404
response is usually sent when the client
is sending a particular resource ID okay
a particular resource a single resource
or a bunch of resource in different
different
representations when the client request
for a particular number of resources or
a single resource that is the use case
when we should send a 404
but if it is a list API call and we
don't have any data let's say the filter
does not match any data let's say in the
params we pass a filter so we pass
status filter and here instead of active
and archived we pass some uh random
value some random value and when we
execute this we are getting data as an
empty array and total is zero page one
total Pages zero this is the kind of
response we get in a list API call this
response code is still 200 because it is
a this is a list API call if you notice
this we are not requesting a particular
organization a particular resource that
is the reason we should not throw 404
here even if we have no data for this
filter we do not say resource not found
we say the data is empty this is a thumb
rule that you have to remember that if
it's a list API call and there is no
data you should return an empty array
with 200 response instead of returning
404 404 is only return When the client
is requesting for a particular entity
which does not exist in the server okay
with that we have covered all the CED
operations C basically means create read
in the read we have get and list we have
update and we have delete cow operations
we have covered all the crow operations
and this is how the typical crowd
operations based API design interface
will look like now what we have a custom
action by custom action I mean we want
to perform some action on the server
which does not fall under any of these
categories it is not a create operation
it is not a get operation or an update
or a delete operation it is a particular
action that we want to perform on a
single organization entry let's say this
is organization five and we want to
Archive organization 5 okay now
archiving an organization
you can on the first look you can
imagine that if we update the status
field of an organization to status
archived then it is archived right so
ideally it should fall under patch right
but that is not the case you want to
perform some action you want don't want
to update an entity even though at the
end of the day it is updating the entity
uh you are updating organization five
from status active to archived but at
the end of the day it is an custom
action because let's say you want to
Archive organization five right you want
to make the status from active to
archived now this is the action that you
want to perform but you cannot simply
just update the status field because
when an organization is archived a lot
of operations will have to be performed
maybe all the projects that resides
under that organization will also have
to get get removed get deleted or some
kind of operation maybe the users that
are involved in that organization have
to be sent notifications or they have to
be sent emails right and all the tasks
that fall under all the projects that
fall under all the organization they
have to be deleted right lot of actions
have to be performed from server side
when a particular organization is
archived that is the reason updating the
status field of an organization from
active to archived is not actually
archiving an organization it at the end
of the day is an custom action you want
to Archive an organization so now we
have a use case where we want to perform
some kind of custom action in this case
the action is want to Archive a
particular organization you want to
perform this custom action on the server
side for a particular organization right
now as I have mentioned before whenever
we have a use case which does not fall
under any of the crud flows it is not a
create get delete or update method then
we can use post with the custom action
to construct an API call to execute that
custom action in the server set so let's
do that in the next API we'll create a
new request and let's rename this to
Archive archive organization right and
here from the name also you can see that
up until here we have crud endpoints we
have delete get update create list right
from the names you can see that these
are crud operations but at the end we
have archive this is not a cud operation
that's why we are classifying it as a
custom action okay now how do you
perform customer action we make it a
post call we make it a post call then we
take uh let's say uh let's execute this
let's remove this and the ID of
oranization 5 is this we take this ID
let's paste this here and before that we
need the servers address for that this
one is the address let's spacee this
here and here we have the service
address here there is the root path with
the organizations then we have passed
which organization like we want to
Archive organization five that's why we
are passing the ID of organization five
then at last we want to write the action
that we want to perform so in this case
it is an archive operation this is an
archive action we have written archive
now we have the route ready okay and if
you notice here this completely follows
a hierarchical relationship that we had
uh mentioned earlier we have the service
address so ignore this part from this
path segment we can see that we have all
organizations inside all organization we
have a single particular organization
and for that organization we want to
perform some action so it is a clear
hierarchical path that your API endpoint
should ideally fall now when we execute
this we are getting a response and in
the response we have the organization
five and the status is archived we have
made organization five from status
active to status archived as a custom
action with post end point right and
even though we have used post here we
still got the Response Code as 200
that's the reason you should not blindly
assume that every post call will have
the Response Code of 2011 which is the
creator Response Code because there
could be also custom actions custom
actions like these which will return 200
because they did not create any resource
they will return 200 for custom API
calls for custom action based API calls
okay now with that we have covered all
the API endpoints for the schema for the
data model organizations okay now with
that we have covered all the API end
points for organization this schema now
let's move on to projects right we will
do this one more time uh so that you can
internalize all the patterns that we are
using while while designing our
endpoints all the patterns that we are
using while designing the interface of
our API okay okay so now let's continue
designing all the apas for projects
right projects endpoints so going back
to
insomnia uh what I've done here I have
created a folder called org and I've
moved all the organization based
endpoints inside the org folder so that
it's easier to manage now that we'll be
creating
all the endpoints for projects this part
is categorized as organization endpoints
now we can minimize this create another
folder and we'll name this as project
and under this let's this let's create
our first request which will be a post
request and this time we'll do this L
still faster since I've already
explained all the concepts behind it in
the previous endpoint creation flows so
this time we'll just uh Focus Fus on the
patterns but we'll move faster so we
have the servers address which is htdp
Local Host and the port is
3,000 slash since we are designing now
the endpoint for project that's why as
our pattern says the plural form of the
resource in small case which gives us
projects okay now this is for the post
AP call okay now this route is ready now
now what should go in the body since
post request uh we are creating a new
project what should go in the body a
Json payload in the Json payload we can
basically send name organization ID
status description because the ID
created at and updated at are server
handle fields we do not uh accept that
from the client payload we are only
accepting name organization ID status
and description so name will be some
project name then organization ID will
be some organization ID that is already
existing and the status will be let's
say planned and the description will be
some kind of description okay so let's
come here and name is let's say project
one then we have
organization id id is some random ID for
now let's not worry about that then we
have status let's say it is planned and
in the end we have description the
description we can pass some back okay
now we have the payload ready now
another thing to notice here is any kind
of Json payloads whether it is a Json uh
any kind of Json data whether it is a
payload that we send from client to
server or it is a response that we
receive from server to client it should
always follow the fields should always
follow camel case right that is a common
standard when it comes to Json so that
is something you have to keep in mind
whether you are accepting payloads or
you are giving responses from server
side always try to stick to Json
standards if you are using Json as your
calization format uh that way uh clients
do not have to do a lot of guess work
because it is already established
pattern that Json Fields always follow
camel case okay now let's hit this and
we got a status 2011 because a new
project is created and we got all the um
fields that we have passed and the
project entity that is created the
typical create a using post let's go
ahead and let's create another request
and it will be a let's rename this to
create project and we'll name this one
to list project okay and this will be as
usual a get call and we can copy the
route of the post call because as I've
already mentioned the routes of create a
resource and list resource will most of
the time look similar and the routes of
get a single resource update a single
resource and delete a single resource
will most of the time look similar
because of the semantic meaning that
comes with them right so we don't have
to make any other changes here it is a
list call and when we send this the
server senses all the projects that is
inside the database okay so in the
create one we can create a few more
project
two project 3 and in the list we can go
ahead and we can do different different
parameters can pass limit as one right
if you pass limit is one we only get one
response but when we add page with limit
and the page is two here we are getting
project three but when we are sending
limit one and page two we'll ideally get
project two because it is the next
portion of the data that we are fetching
from the server similarly this will also
have sorts this will also have filters
that we have already discussed in the
previous endpoint while we are uh
dealing with list organizations endo
right we have create projects and we
have list projects now another thing I
want to mention here is when you are
designing apis uh for a particular
platform right as long as you are inside
a single project so all the apis inside
that project does not matter what the
resources are here we have two resources
we have organization and we have project
but across different resources your
query parameters and your Json payload
should look similar and what I mean by
that is let's say in the create
organization if you see the body you can
see the name uh the project has an
organization has name and it has
description and we are expecting those
fields from the client now similarly in
the create project also we have name and
we also have description that we are
expecting from the client now the point
I'm trying to make here is you should
always try to be consistent when it
comes to the Json payloads so so in the
create organization API you made
description the key of description like
this so in the create project API also
we have to uh you should keep the key
similar you should not like go ahead and
DSC right this also expresses that this
field is associated with the description
field but since you already have an API
where the Json payload contains a
description field from that point on all
all the apis that you design should
follow a consistent pattern and if it's
a description field then you should only
uh then you should try to match that you
should not try to rename Fields when the
context is the same because because
usually what happens when a front end
engineer when some kind of client right
they integrate your API they consume one
API they integrate one API and from that
point on that frontend engineer that uh
client they make a lot of assumptions of
how your API functions they make
assumptions that let's say this is a
create organization API right from this
point on when they want to integrate the
project endpoints they will make a lot
of assumptions that the since the
project also has a name field since the
project also has a description field
this is what the payload will look like
for a project and it did look like that
because that's the way you have designed
it but imagine if you made the
description field as
DSC and the client the front end
engineer without looking at the docs
without looking at the specs of your API
they executed the API right with the
description field and they get a
validation error now of course uh during
development these kind of these kinds of
things happen and that's totally fine
but the point is you should not waste um
the people who are integrating your AP
you should not waste their time and you
should not waste their effort you should
not make them do guess work right your
API should always follow a consistent
pattern whether it comes to routes or
whether it comes to payloads whether it
comes to responses always follow
consistent pattern once you create an
API stick to that standard whatever
styling that you have followed stick to
that not make arbitrary decisions across
different different resources for
different different end points right
always be consistent that's one of the
most important characteristic of a good
backend engineer the consistency of
styling when it comes to API design
similarly for list for create
organization here we followed this
pattern where uh the route is
organizations the plural form of the
resource now for the projects part let's
say if we had did just project right now
the person who is integrating your API
judging and assuming from your create
organization API they'll they'll assume
that the create project API must also
follow the plural form right because
that's what the organizations API
followed so if you do not follow the
same style if you do not be consistent
then they'll also get an error at that
then they have to figure out they have
to read the specs they have to read the
documentation etc etc right which is a
lot of drag and that is the reason uh
that is the importance of sticking
sticking to a particular style sticking
to a global standard now let's move on
let's create the rest of the apis we
also have a get API let's create the
rest of the apis we also have a get
project API so what we can do copy this
let paste this we have projects and up
to this point we have to pass the
project ID because it is a single
project fetching API it is a get API
which fetches a single projects that's
why in the dynamic parameter you have to
pass the ID of the project now let's
execute this uh list projects and list
this parameters and execute this let's
copy some ID and in this let's rename
this one to project and let's paste this
ID and when we execute this we got the
response for a single project right
ideally uh with the Response Code of 200
similarly let's go ahead and create the
update API let's rename this project
okay and here also we can let's copy the
get project and here we can paste it as
I've already mentioned the routes of get
single resource update single resource
and delete single resource will always
look similar because of the semantic
meaning that they represent behind the
scenes now this is an update API so will
do patch because we are sending partial
Fields right and this will re require
some kind of body so this what should we
update the description let's update the
description we are say the description
is the existing description is some
random value we'll change it so in the
body we can send partial Fields so we
just need to send the value of the new
description field and here we can say
that new description okay and when we
send this we get a 20 when we send this
we got a 200 response because it is a
patch request and we got the updated
entity and as you can see the
description is new description yeah
that's the typical behavior of patch
similarly let's implement the delete
request this one inside project new
request and let's rename let's rename
this to delete project okay and we can
just copy this because it is a single
project API and we make this method as
delete and there will be no body Etc
right and I can send this and as usual
since it is a delete method we got a 204
no content response and there is nothing
in the response because it is a delete
request and at last we have a custom
action so in case of project we have a
requirement that the client the front
end can clone a particular project and
when they clone it what happens that
project all the values of that project
gets cloned and a new project with a
different ID is created in the database
with that other operations might also
get executed in the server side which we
don't know about that is the reason it
is a custom action and it is not a
create action we could have also done
that uh the client would also call the
create project API and it could take all
the values from the existing project it
could pass uh all of them in the payload
and create a new project with the all
the same values it could simulate a
cloning operation but but we don't know
what clone means on the server side
right if project clone can also mean
that we have to take all the tasks that
are inside that project and we have to
also clone them right and maybe we have
to send an email to the owner of the
project that your project have cloned ET
right the server maybe has to perform a
lot of other operations when a project
is cloned that is the reason we cannot
simulate cloning operation using just a
create project API right we have to
explicitly create an
endo uh with a custom action for cloning
okay so let's go ahead and do that let's
create a new one let's rename this clone
project and this will be post call as
you already know all the custom actions
which do not fall under any crud
operations are categorized under post
because post is an open-ended method
when it comes to rest APS specification
so let's copy this one because the route
will be similar we want to clone this
particular project right let's paste
this at the end we just write the name
of the action this is how we designed a
custom action based API we have the
servers address
we have the resource in the plural form
we have the particular resource that we
want to perform the action on and at
last the name of the action this is what
the structure of the API looks like and
it does not have any payload uh for this
use case but maybe you can take payloads
maybe you can take um some fields that
the client wants to override for a clone
operation okay now when we execute this
we get a project not found and 404
response because we already deleted this
project so let's go ahead and pick up a
new project and replace this ID and then
we execute this and we got it 20 one
response now as I said you cannot assume
from the method that since this the post
method it will be a 20 1 response or
since it is a custom action it cannot
return 2011 because depending on what
happens on the server side the Response
Code might change because during in
cloning the server creates a new project
that's why the server returned a
response which says
2011 which means I created a new
resource for you okay we got a 2011
response and the newly created resource
and the name is Project to clone and all
the fields that are similar to the
project 2 entry that we had next this is
the custom action based API for projects
endpoint and with that all end points of
project resource are completed hopefully
by now you are able to establish all the
patterns that goes behind designing all
these apis and if you were to design all
the apis for task so you would follow
the same kind of pattern right you'll
have a list API you'll have a get single
task API you'll have delete update and
you'll have some kind of Uh custom
action right the patterns are same does
not matter how many resources do you
have the patterns still remain the same
with these patterns you can go out and
design as many apis as you want right
the basics are the same the foundation
is still the same now with that out of
the way there are a couple of things
that you have to keep in mind while you
are creating your apas to provide a good
experience to whoever is integrating
your apas and whoever is maintaining
your apas always try to provide an
interactive documentation for your apas
uh for for example start integrating
Swagger tools like Swagger API which
provide uh an interactive playground for
trying out your apas right start
planning that from your initial planning
so that even so that you can use it to
test your apas and whoever is
integrating your apas they can use it as
a form of documentation and as a form of
testing right that's the first thing
this is very important and one of the
most important things that sets part as
a backend engineer how consistently and
how frequently you uh create maintain
and update your open API or Swagger
documentation second thing is make your
apis intuitive and consistent which I've
already mentioned all your routes all
the patterns when it comes to your
Dynamic parameters when you or custom
actions or Json payloads all of them
should follow a single pattern so if
your following the global pattern the
global standards of rest API then that's
great right but even if you're not
following that for some reason for some
random reason that I cannot understand
even if you cannot follow it but follow
something right and stick to it do not
change your styling do not change your
patterns of your API in different
different end points across different
different resources right that is a huge
pain point for or whoever is trying to
integrate your apis keep the behavior
keep the data format keep the naming
everything consistent and intuitive
third provide CN defaults and by this I
mean uh as we saw in the pag generation
API right even if the client does not
pass a default page the server sets the
default page as one if the client does
not pass a limit parameter the default
limit is 10 or 20 if the client does not
part pass a sort field the default field
is created at if the sort order is not
passed the default sort order is
descending similarly for post calls
let's say there is a post operation in
that case only require the amount of
information that you absolutely need to
create that entity otherwise provide
some same defaults so even if it's a uh
post call there are some fields for
example in our earlier create
organization API there is a field for
status if you see here the organization
has a field for status which can have
active or archived but judging from the
business logic judging from common sense
right you can assume that when an
organization is created by default it
should be in active state right so from
the client if the client does not pass
the status field the server should by
default set the status as active because
it is a same default that part you can
assume and it is a safe assumption so
for feels like status you can take some
status entry which makes most sense for
your use case and provide that as a same
default so that for creating an
organization even if the client just
passes name and a description and since
the description is optional here even if
the client just passes a name this
organization is is successfully created
with status active because on the server
side you have provided same defaults
that's what we mean by same defaults
both in get a calls in post a calls
similarly always avoid abbreviations uh
like DEC for description etc etc right
because the amount of information you
have while creating apis while creating
the interface for your apas is not the
same amount of information that the
people will have who are integrating
your apis right so you cannot assume
that if you provided some kind of
abbreviation or some kind of short form
of a field the people will be able to
understand that and will be able to
provide a appropriate entry for that
field and that is the reason keep your
peels whether it is payloads or whether
it is query parameters keep them
intuitive keep them readable and do not
use use abbreviations and stuff right
now these are just a couple of things
that you have to keep in mind while
designing your API interfaces and that
is pretty much all that I have about API
designing uh hopefully it will help you
uh make decisions make good decisions
make decisions faster and stick to a
particular standards so that it is
easier for people who are maintaining
your apis and it is easier for people
who are integrating and consuming your
apis in the future as a backend engineer
that's your responsibility to provide
delightful to provide intuitive apis and
always remember that an API a rest API
at least is designed in the initial form
it is not coded or it is not programmed
right away at the first at the first
phase of the API creation it is
designed you have to make a lot of
decisions to design your apis you cannot
right away jump into programming that is
the reason if you start uh with an open
API playground like Swagger or some kind
of um API clients like insomnia or
Postman to design the interface for your
apis it will provide you more insights
into how your clients or how the
consumers of your apis are going to use
it and that will make you think and that
will make you make your apis in a much
better way in a much more intuitive way
and that is the reason before getting
into
the coding part the programming of the
API part regardless of the programming
language that you're using whether it is
go whether it is notes or any other
language you should dedicate a separate
session a separate session for just
designing your interface the designing
the interface for your apis without
thinking about programming languages
that's the reason in this video we did
not uh talk about programming languages
or language specific or framework
specific implementation at all right we
only focused on designing the interface
for our apis with this we'll end this
video and ideally and hopefully you
should be able to create delightful and
intuitive apas from now on